c'est l'exercice le plus difficile de
l'émission vous allez devoir répondre à
une interview avec baffie dans votre
oreille
c'est le ba fille dans l'oreillette est
ce que laurent baffie est en place on me
dit que oui
alors attention je choisis une série de
questions je branche mais aurait
agrémenté de rayer toute une série de
questions
allez vas-y lois nos répondants
respectons et crache à la gueule de
hockey ben oui je pense que jamais sans
doute bien que c'est très bien pourquoi
est-ce de la boule noire fils 2
la gueule chérie façon motus quand tu
décrire est ta carrière tu fais bien de
me poser la question en trente années de
merde à brasser déboula c'était quoi
c'est quoi l'âge moyen des gens dans le
public à motus je te dise y avait le
louvre qui loue prêtait des momies
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toutes les questions je te réponds après
29 ans de motus tu aimeras ni un autre
jeu lotus
tout le monde se torcher le cul lotus
bah oui et tout le monde se torcher le
cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est quoi la principale qualité de
la présidente de france télévisions
delphine ernotte un bon ben c'est une
bombe
c'est une bombe le défaut est le défaut
ben comme toutes les bombes ça te pète à
la gueule parfois l'habitude d'entendre
parler comme ça il ya là ça calme mais
c'est bien c'est quoi ton insultes
préféré au lit d'une morano lui
ouais je te le dis parce que c'est toi
nadine morano
si tu devenais président quelle serait
ta première mesure
pardonne moi je crois que je poserai la
femme de l'oeuf
[Applaudissements]
je suis possédé pas ce qui m'arrive
match à sentir ici tu le fais motus
je lis tout ce que je te demande quelque
chose que personne ne sait sur toi je te
le dis
j'ai jamais dit fait dire des choses la
question essentielle bojan je suis têtu
c'est j'ai une boule noire
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais dit surtout jamais montré
ma gloire mais c'est pour thierry
beccaro magnifique suit avec a joué le
jeu à fond vab ont beaucoup parce que
c'est que c'est pas facile
[Applaudissements]